- It's that time to scroll the pages
of the interwebs to bring you the best.
This is what I'm liking.
A few years ago, Boston
couple Kate and Dave
had a wedding so epic it went viral.
That's because the wedding party surprised
the bride with a flash mob,
dancing to My Life Would Suck Without You.
Great song choice, is all I'm saying
and a great reaction
from the bride as well.
Not long after she got
another big surprise,
Dave took Kate to one of
my shows, not knowing Dave
and my team plotted to
bring her up on stage
and her reaction again was priceless.
Now they're celebrating another
big moment in their lives
and I have them on the line to share it.
So hi Kate, hi Dave.
Hi.
Well it's awesome to see y'all again.
So, so many great moments Kate.
- I know, I know, I honestly
can't even put into words
which one is my favorite like,
I was gonna say my concert,
your concert or my wedding.
I called the whole wedding, my concert.
It was just like, I was
so excited at my wedding,
I definitely peed my
dress so I had to change
into another dress that
I had in the closet,
and it was like $20, but
that's neither here nor there
because it was totally worth it.
But I just, after that,
I kept saying to Dave,
I'm like nothing will ever top that moment
unless I one, meet Kelly
or two, have a baby
and so I met you so I feel
like my dream came true.
- Awe I love that, it
was so awesome to get
to see y'all too, but wait Dave,
y'all have some news to share, right?
- We do, we do, so we are having a baby.
- Yeah.
- Yay.
Thank you.
- That's so exciting, I
feel like I've been a part
of your relationship
from the beginning y'all.
I feel like I'm part of it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well I have-
- I feel more-
- We can be, we can be, well
my team did some finagling
and got access to your little
one's gender, so just saying,
the answer is right inside this cake,
which happens to have been baked
by Courtney Rich who was just here,
she's amazing so it's
going to taste awesome.
Kate and Dave, are you ready?
Cause you don't know yet.
Boy or girl, you don't know.
- No, we don't.
- I'm so nervous.
- Okay.
- We could've known about two
months ago but we held on so.
- Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Our relationship is beautiful you guys.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, wait, wait.
It's a girl, that's a girl.
It's a girl.
You're gonna have a little girl.
I love you guys.
Oh my gosh.
Congratulations.
You guys, our baby girl
is going to be awesome.
- Yes, yes it is, yes she is.
- I love you guys, I'm so happy for you.
You gotta come visit whenever
you have the little one,
little Kelly and I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
I'm liking your posts right now, okay?
This cake looks awesome.
Okay.
I just wanted to show you,
this is for you not me.
That's not all that you
guys, our season long partner
Pilot Pen, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show.
Thinks both of you are
as awesome as we do.
So in recognition, they'd
like to write you a check
with their G2 gelling pen
for a thousand dollars.
How does that sound?
- Thank you so much.
- That's amazing.
- We love you, I love you guys so much.
I'm so happy for y'all.
Congratulations.
- I love you.
- Lil baby girl.